[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 Jorge Hurtado con nosotros en el
estudio Jorge buena mañana del lunes
comenzamos una nueva semana informativa
aquí en directo América y nos vamos a
Reino Unido porque el nuevo ministro de
finanzas británico
casi todo este mini presupuesto de la
primera ministra listros tan polémico no
Así es un proyecto bastante ambicioso y
precisamente esa era parte de la tarea
de Home tratar de calmar a los mercados
financieros que estaban bastante
agitados en las últimas semanas
precisamente por este mini presupuesto
agitados desde hace semanas por este
plan de recortes Fiscales que propuso
precisamente la nueva también nueva
primera ministra todo el gobierno es
nueva y en Reino Unido según home los
cambios en los recortes Fiscales
previstos permitirían recaudar 32 mil
millones de libras esos son
aproximadamente unos 36.000 millones de
dólares cada año entre los cambios se
encuentra la suspensión indefinida de un
plan de para recortar el tipo básico de
impuesto sobre la renta así como reducir
el plan de tope de precios de la energía
que había anunciado el gobierno en plena
crisis energética en Europa otros
cambios Fiscales previstos que había
propuesto otros fueron eliminados como
el recorte del impuesto sobre los
dividendos la creación de un nuevo plan
de compras sin iva y la congelación de
los tipos del impuesto sobre el alcohol
así como regulaciones para los
trabajadores autónomos ahí trozos y su
anterior ministro de finanzas cuasi
cuarting presentaron el 23 de septiembre
este plan de 50.000 millones de dólares
en recortes Fiscales no financiados que
asustaron a los mercados financieros
llevaron a la libra a mínimos históricos
y obligaron al banco de Inglaterra a
tomar inclusive a intervenir para tomar
medidas de emergencia traje el anuncio
la libra esterlina amplió su ganancias
frente al Dólar hasta subir un 1,2%,
mientras los precios de la deuda pública
también subieron escuchemos sí parte de
lo que decía el nuevo ministro de
finanzas de Reino Unido
Buenos días una responsabilidad central
de cualquier gobierno es hacer lo
necesario para la estabilidad económica
esto es vital para las empresas que
toman decisiones de inversión a largo
plazo y para las familias preocupadas
por sus empleos sus hipotecas y el coste
de vida
Markets ningún gobierno puede controlar
los mercados pero todos los gobiernos
pueden dar seguridad sobre la
sostenibilidad de las finanzas públicas
y ese es uno de los muchos factores que
influyen en el comportamiento de los
mercados y por esta razón Aunque la
primera ministra y yo estamos
comprometidos con el recorte de
impuestos de sociedades el viernes
escuchó las preocupaciones sobre el mini
presupuesto y confirmó que no Seguiremos
adelante con el recorte de impuestos de
sociedades anunciados
Jorge en China en el contexto del
congreso del partido comunista Se
esperan por supuesto datos económicos
Así es Hay un dicho que dice que si
china estornuda le da gripe al mundo y
es por eso que este dato tan importante
según un alto funcionario la economía
china mostró un importante repunte en el
tercer trimestre y el empleo se mantuvo
en gran medida estable según South
chanching subdirector de la Comisión
Nacional de desarrollo y Reforma la
segunda economía mundial se salvó por
nada de una contracción en el segundo
trimestre ya que las restricciones del
covid 19 y la creciente caída del sector
inmobiliario pesan sobre las
perspectivas económicas china va a
retrasar si la publicación de los datos
del producto interno bruto del tercer
trimestre y de la actividad de
septiembre cuya publicación estaba
prevista inicialmente para este martes
según un calendario actualizado en la
página web de la oficina de estadísticas
no se dio ninguna explicación de Por qué
retrasaron los datos la economía china
probablemente creció así un 3,4% entre
julio y septiembre respecto al año
anterior ganando un ritmo respecto al
crecimiento del 0,4% del segundo
trimestre pero el crecimiento previsto
para 2022 podría seguir siendo uno de
los más débiles en casi medio siglo
según las encuestas china prometió
ampliar su apertura e impulsar una
globalización más beneficiosa para todos
dijeron en medio de críticas de
instituciones como la Unión Europea que
acusan al gigante asiático de anteponer
la ideología el crecimiento o de
alejarse del todo el mundo Jorge y
también esta semana Será difícil en
Francia esto por la huelga de las
refinerías Así es la huelga está
confirmada que continuará para las
refinerías y depósitos en Francia esta
semana según la confederación general
del trabajo un 30,1% de la gasolinera
del país no tienen carburante de acuerdo
con los últimos datos actualizados por
el ejecutivo la continuidad de esta
huelga es algo inaceptable e ilegítimo
esto Dijo el ministro de economía y
finanzas pero no le mear esto porque el
viernes se logró un acuerdo entre la
dirección de la compañía total Energy y
dos sindicatos la central exige un
incremento general del 10% para los
trabajadores de total energe para
compensar el alza de la inflación pero
también para que participen en los
beneficios extras que está obteniendo la
compañía Precisamente en el contexto de
la crisis energética la huelga en la
gasolinera se expandirá a la educación
ya que muchos padres no podrán enviar a
sus hijos a las escuelas o no tendrán
profesores para clases también el
transporte público será uno de Los
afectados en Francia Así es Y mañana
también que se espera está mega marcha
con varios sindicatos ahí pues se
protestando y no hay buenos pronósticos
para la economía de la eurozona Jorge
Bueno se espera una contracción el
próximo año como consecuencia del
aumento de Los costos de la energía y el
riesgo de escasez tras la invasión rusa
de Ucrania la producción del bloque
caería al 0,1% en 2023 según los
economistas encuestados por Boom
bloomberg que hace un mes todavía
estimaban un crecimiento del 0,3%.
Alemania que es la mayor economía de la
zona del euro se contraería un 0,5%,
mientras Francia Italia y España
probablemente crecerán Pese a que el
Banco Central europeo contempla que
Alemania evite dos trimestres
consecutivos de contracción El
vicepresidente del banco Luis de guindos
afirmó que no descarta la recesión
técnica para la mayor economía europea
la inflación de la eurozona se sitúa
ahora en una media del 5,5 según la
encuesta Alemania fue el país que más
revisó sus previsiones al alza entre las
principales economías del bloque Jorge
como siempre Gracias por toda la
información económica más adelante más
economía
[Música]